Panda Express to me is like white people
Chinese food hola jungle turn top door
Willam hammer this is so gross
wow this looks like a candle john-boy
I'm trying Dina
yo man PA betrayal and you mean the ship
yeah about the Baha
it's like soggy on the inside was it
just a way down table daughter don't you
Peter the Hudson oh boy look the old man
if you actually know like real Chinese
chow mein you'd be like this is like
American China Charlie so go told me not
gone oh it smells like stinky feet
I tell you look go home it actually
tastes pretty like authentic oh wow you
never heard thunder change yeah this is
like George I'd rather eat this on a go
put it that way
hello standards that's I end up with her
leave us down and express what he needs
McDonald's all the time like I don't
understand
no wait I see hotties I'm Jessica should
you go we go other things I was it
looking as Melanie likes it
I couldn't you online hmm good job says
pink
supid that chef bouche young what the
addition if you blindfold me I'm eating
plain ice god tastes like cardboard
muscle bigger than them Seymour this
young maid did you know I mean how would
I tell ha
so much huh this is all right future Wow
your son knock on [ __ ] like a tweet
don't so named tickle but Sir it's
really sorry
mmm I do not like that
nope no shallots and sendeth no wait the
head Shan Shan back I'm Trisha Dean does
reminds me of taking shots like the bad
aftertaste people does it they don't
like it this is my dad's name like if
you were here you would hate hums Oh
smell it smells all good yeah smells
weird I like this I was really salty oh
man
Kouga by a needle you go Shambu
Zhongshan genican bhaji bouche young one
chicken is not your Chinese food my mom
calls it like the food that falls
Americans I may call anyway so so - yeah
oh no no I know what this is burnt soy
sauce not sure what that is you know to
be just to hook humming oh hell no I go
tight keep shootin chicken it'll die
soon am I gonna be oh yeah you with a
hill Hallman
this chicken is sad was awesome huh
Candice finish all those little orange
chicken pieces is so good go I can't
imagine anyone thinking that pandas
actually Chinese food well I do you go
get home a Samoan Sakuya see out
Doughboy insignia just me consider don't
em up me burnin out your tires young
woman can hold its own time yeah but you
know what my dad used to always say is
that you can't you know
leave one grain of rice on the board
yeah that's all my mom's because I don't
like with you food why did you not get
that when you're over no all the
department of rice